bonjour marie sa merci beaucoup d'être
en direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france alors on a vu à quoi ressemblait
ce mouvement qui commence à naître sur
les réseaux sociaux
quelle est l'ampleur de ce mouvement et
pouvez vous nous l'expliquer un il
s'inspire évidemment de ce qui se passe
au canada
oui on s'inspire du canada bien entendu
alors déjà je suis assez surprise parce
que j'ai entendu pas mal de choses
erronées
allez-y je vous en prie donc tout
d'abord il n'y a absolument aucune
convergence sur paris même notre
objectif c'est d'aller à la capitale
européenne qui est bruxelles et c'est là
où nous présenterons nos revendications
nous ne bloquerons pas paris quand j'ai
évidemment dans la presse que ces
informations sont distillées le 14
février dont vous irez à bruxelles c'est
ça oui c'est ça avec tous les autres
pays européens
alors dites-nous pour quelles raisons
dans les raisons parce que c'est la
capitale européenne et on avait besoin
tout ce pays européens ce camp on est en
lien quotidien avec les autres pays
d'europe donc de se retrouver on se
retrouve à notre capital très bien donc
on a vu que ce mouvement s'inspirer de
celui au canada c'est le coût de la vie
le pass vaccinale quelles sont les
raisons de cette de cette colère
lampard contre la présentation était
exact nous avons nous avons donc
beaucoup de revendications qui touche un
petit peu tous les domaines donc là tout
d'abord bien sûr la faim permanente du
pass la liberté de déplacement le droit
de décider pour notre santé et l'accès
aux soins pour tous la liberté
d'expression le respect de la dignité
humaine et droit de vivre dignement de
son travail ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui où de ses revenus issus de
la solidarité le droit travail pour tous
et sans condition garantir le respect
des droits de l'enfant et la
préservation son épanouissement l'accès
à la culture et à l'enseignement pour
tous et le droit une réelle démocratie
participative pour tous les citoyens
et qu'elle est long on a vu qu'il y
avait cent soixante dix mille déjà
partisan en tout cas sûr sur la page
facebook vous c'est que ce mouvement
sera suivi
alors oui oui je pense qu'il sera suivi
les retours de terrain sont extrêmement
positifs tout le monde se mobilise à
tous les niveaux on a prévu donc
différents trajets avec des points de
pose de déjeuner et de nuitées et à
chaque endroit où les houles et et les
pauses les ont été mises on a déjà des
personnes des collectifs qui se met en
marche pour pour organiser du
ravitaillement des personnes on assure
le télégramme qu'on veuille france des
propositions et d'hébergement et on a
aussi en traître qu'on veuille france
qui est un groupe il ya un groupe
télégramme où chacun peut déposer ses
propositions alors est-ce que c'est
exclusivement réservé c'est celui d'hier
ont regoûté non non non bien entendu
on voit france
ça va être beaucoup beaucoup de citoyens
la législation fait que les routiers ne
peuvent pas se permettre de prendre le
camion de leur employeur
pour pour converger vers bruxelles donc
ils vont être là certains avec leurs
camions mais la majorité sera dans des
berlines et non volant de leur cabine
alors on peut pas s'empêcher évidemment
de faire le lien avec ce qui s'était
passé pour les gilets jaunes mouvement
qui a débuté avec la hausse du prix des
carburants on a vu qu'il y avait aussi
cette question de la hausse du prix des
péages que l'on va voir juste après
votre interview ce coût de la vie cette
ce mécontentement est il comparable au
mouvement des filets jaunes selon vous
je pense qu'il est plus large il couvre
bien sûr ce que déjà décrié les gilets
jaunes mais là c'est vraiment une
atteinte à nos libertés qui est fait à
nos droits fondamentaux
donc il ya beaucoup il ya bien entendu
des gilets jaunes
ça groupe beaucoup beaucoup plus de
personnes je pense que là tout le monde
se sent concerné par nos revendications
alors on a vu des manifestations anti
passe sanitaires
en belgique où qui vont converger des
personnes venant de toute l'europe est
ce que ce sera le cas aussi pour pour le
mouvement du convoi de la liberté le 14
février est ce que des pays européens
aussi se joindre à votre mouvement oui
bien entendu oui on en relation qu'on
veuille français dans leur relation avec
leurs convois et donc on sera tous
ensemble à bruxelles le 14 et aucun
blocage soyez rassurés parisien aucun
blocage est prévu à paris n'iront pas
dans paris d'ailleurs le mot d'ordre
c'est le vendredi à notre arrivée en
région parisienne que les personnes qui
ont trouvé un hébergement aillent
directement vers cet hébergement ensuite
le samedi midi nous nous retrouverons
pour un pique nique en région parisienne
toujours il nous semblait nécessaire de
nous retrouver tous français ce que ça
fait deux ans qu'on nous distancier
qu'on nous sépare donc on avait besoin
d'union de se retrouver tous donc on
fera un pique nique un lieu qui sera
déterminée qui est déterminé mais qu'on
donnera au dernier moment pour passer un
moment agréable avant notre convergence
vers bruxelles et qui interpellait vous
en particulier le gouvernement j'imagine
et pour quelques que lui demandez vous
concrètement bon lui demande d'arrêter
de suspendre non de mettre fin aux lois
liberticides qui sont sanitaires qui ont
été mises en place depuis deux ans et
puis bien sûr on aimerait aussi avoir
des commission denquête sur la gestion
qui a été faite
voilà en gros en gros c'est ça et puis
aussi des retours sur
la situation de nos de nos enfants de
nos jeunes qui sont en très grandes
difficultés et souffrances
millions prévus demain du gouvernement
pour a priori assouplir ces mesures on
verra cela merci beaucoup varicent a en
tout cas de nous avoir répondu ce matin
dans la matinale et d'avoir rectifié en
tout cas les inexactitudes sur sur votre
mouvement
convoi france merci